welcome to Microsoft security risk
detection today you will see how to use
Microsoft security risk detection to
find million-dollar bugs
using the same technology Microsoft uses
for testing our own products and
services this technology creates a let
fuzz lab in the cloud with support for
both Windows and Linux to get started
visit dub dub dub microsoft security
risk detection comm that will show you
the portal for a microsoft security risk
detection the portal is your one-stop
shop for controlling security testing
and viewing what has been done in
security testing today we're going to
focus on the fuzzing part of the portal
we have a separate video for talking
about the web scanning part which we'll
discover later today I have three
fuzzing jobs a job is one piece of
software being tested in one lab one of
the jobs is starting to initialize one
of the jobs is ready for me to upload
software for fuzzing and one of the jobs
is already underway I will talk to you
first about the results you get from
fuzzing and how to look at the progress
of a job then we will see how to submit
a job how to configure it and how to
create a whole lab running in the cloud
of your very own to attack your software
before hackers do let's look at this job
is currently fuzzing it started on the
18th of March 2019 the job already has
17 results let's click on the results
page and see what the results look like
Microsoft security risk detection is
throwing millions and millions of test
cases at your program this program is
called calendar reader calendar reader
is a wrapper around a library called
calendar Lib calendar Lib is a library
that reads those Cal files which we all
use to infect our each other's calendars
now over here I
can filter out all the results by
severity
I can see crashes meaning that the the
program actually crashed or I can see
first chance exceptions which means
something happened but the program was
able to continue without crashing I'm
going to focus on the crashes I click on
the crashes and boom I can see all of
the things that caused crashes so I can
see here there are three what we call
buckets the first bucket is divide by 0
the second bucket is a read access
violation and the third buck is a read
access violation these are the types of
issues that were found by the fuzzing
process so here a divide by 0 means that
the program crashed when Tim T divided
by 0 whereas read access violation means
that the program attempted to read
memory it should not have been reading
here I can also see that the read access
violation has a small marker saying that
we believe this violation is exploitable
if an attacker found it the attacker may
be able to use this to take control of
your computer or someone else's computer
running your software I'm interested in
the exploitable violation so I'm going
to go ahead and click on the link here
and learn more about it when I click on
the link I see 3 thinks I see the call
stack where the problem was found I can
see the instances showing the
information on how many times this has
been found during fuzzing in this case
it's been found 1 2 3 4 5 different
times by a Microsoft security risk
detection Microsoft security risk
detection is deduplicating different
issues and attempting to find the issues
of the same root cause so these are 5
different test cases which we believe
have the same root cause and finally I
can see the debugger logs right here in
the portal showing me what happened in
the debugger logs if I scroll down I can
see that there are some access
violations which were first chance
they were handled the program continued
and then here I see ups the axis
violation the memory is being read that
should not be read and here it's a
second chance and the program is
completely crashed and I can see the
complete call stack where the crash
happened
and I can see more information about
what has happened to the program now if
I want to actually get the test case
that caused the crash all I have to do
is Dow is put the download button here
Microsoft security risk detection
captures every single test case that
causes a crash Microsoft security risk
detection reruns the test case is
multiple times to see that they can
crash over and over again so you have
confidence before reporting them to your
colleagues and asking them to fix
something when I click the download
button I get a zip file that contains
information on the crashes let's open
the zip file and see what that looks
like
I'm opening the zip file and inside the
zip file I see five different Cal Files
so remember we're testing today
something called calendar reader
calendar reader reads Cal files each of
these five different files if fed to
calendar reader would cause the same
crash that was reported in the portal
for Microsoft security risk detection we
have an API not shown in this video
which allows you to programmatically
download all of these different Cal
files and then send them to your
colleagues later you will see how that
API is used under the hood to do
integrations with Azure DevOps and
Microsoft teams to help you and your
colleagues more effectively use
Microsoft security risk detection in
your workflow so the zip file contains
the five test cases that cause all
caused this specific problem and the
folder called crashes if I look in the
phone
Crash's it says okay it's read access
violation this number is called the hash
the crash hash is a unique identifier
for the specific issue that was found by
Microsoft security risk detection this
is a unique ID which distinguishes this
issue from other read access violations
or other issues found in the same
program and now I can see for every one
of those five input files there are logs
which allow me or my colleagues to
understand better for each of these five
input files what exactly has happened
and inside I can see a script that
reproduces the issue the output of the
windows debugger the standard error
standard out and some metadata about
that so here this gives me everything
that I need in order to understand more
about what exactly has happened to cause
this particular issue I'm now going to
close this and I'm going to show you how
you can create a new went Microsoft
security was detection job just like
this one that helps you find issues in
your code so what I do is I'm closing
this I click on the security risk
detection link up here at the top this
takes me back to the dashboard and at
the dashboard again I can see all of the
jobs I am I've created for testing my
windows software or my Linux software
here you can see one of the jobs
currently underway is a Linux is a Linux
job that means it's testing Linux in the
cloud what and these other two are
Windows so how do I create a job it's
pretty simple I push the button called
create job Microsoft security risk
detection offers two methods for
creating jobs in one method you have
complete control over the entire virtual
machine which is used for submitting a
job you can install kernel drivers you
can change registry keys you can do
whatever you want
alternatively some
applications fit into what we call a
package a package is a zip file that
contains everything you need in order to
fuzz package submission is faster
package submission allows Microsoft
security risk detection to more quickly
spin up a lab but we found some
customers need the flexibility of the
full virtual machine if you are in doubt
talk to your account development mat
your application development manager
Technical Account Manager for guidance
on which one is right for you today I am
going to remote to a virtual machine and
I am going to pick the standard job tier
we have on Linux we have support the AFL
testing method it's one of the portfolio
of fuzzers that Microsoft security risk
detection uses but today I'm going to
use the standard tier which gives me the
best optimized lab size and composition
for testing applications I now a choice
do I want Server 2008 Server 2016 or
Linux Red Hat
64-bit today I'm going to take the
Server 2008 r2 and when you create a job
and you can see that the job is now
starting to work it's initializing
and I get a notice here saying what my
quota looks like and if I'm running low
on jobs and if I need to do more well
I've already created as Windows job so
now let me show you what that looks like
while we wait for this to initialize
under the hood Microsoft security risk
detection is spinning up a machine in
the Azure cloud just for you just so you
can put anything you want on that
machine and a Microsoft security risk
detection can run millions of test cases
for you but how do I get started
well I get started by clicking on the
open link the open link for the job lets
me see the status of the job and gives
me the ability to log in to a virtual
machine in order to configure it for
testing so I've clicked on the open link
I see the overview which tells me about
about the job what kind of operating
system it is when it was created I'm
going to click on the preparation link
preparation link gives me a username and
a password for remote desktop
information to the machine so I'm going
to click this remote connect and Remote
Connect is downloading an RDP file a
Remote Desktop Protocol file I'm going
to open that and it connects me to
machine in the cloud so I can see here I
am connecting to a machine using the
remote desktop program that is connect
into my copy of Windows my username is
customer that matches the username here
and for password I can click the copy
link here it says click the copy it says
copied now I can just go ahead go
straight back to RDP I'll hit the
remember me so I don't have to enter
this password again and click OK and now
I'm securing the remote connection I'm
getting everything set up in order to
connect to the machine in the cloud and
it just gives me a second while I get
access to a machine has been created
just for me in the azure cloud just for
the software I want to torture today I
now am connecting to the machine and
what I've done on the side here is I've
actually created already pre provisioned
the calendar reader application that I
want to test so what I have is I have
downloaded and made ready the calendar
reader application that I want here and
we're going to copy it over to the
virtual machine and we're going to test
this calendar reader application so in
just a few minutes the machine boots up
logs me and creates my account and gets
everything ready for first use so while
I'm doing that I've got my calendar
reader application I've got that ready
and in fuzzing also requires what we
call as seed files which are some
initial unit tests or initial
information that has used for starting
the fuzzing process well that's ok
because I've already got those as well I
have here a bunch of Cal Files
none of these cause crashes but these
are all part of my unit tests my
functionality tests for my calendar
reader
program so all I have to do is get at
least one of these more the better under
the hood our system will make sense of
anything that you end up giving it by
using code coverage in order to pick the
best set of seed files and then over
here we're just waiting for the machine
to get started so while I'm waiting for
the machine to get started here I can go
ahead and extract all of the files that
I have for my seed files and I'm just
going to open them with a particular I'm
going to just go show you what's inside
of one of these just by opening up with
notepad there's an example of one of my
seed files so your software is gonna be
different but this is an example of what
one of those files looks like it's just
a standard Cal file it happens to be
referring to an interview or a meeting
with a fellow named Spartacus Smith
Spartacus at contoso comm so we can see
here that we're preparing the desktop
we're getting ready for first use and if
I want to I can even just put this into
a window while I go and take a look at
the rest of what's happening on my
machine so here we are we're getting
ready to start our fuzzing process by
configuring a virtual machine and
configuring the virtual machine with the
software that we want to test so we're
preparing our desktop we're getting
ready and then now we have finished
logging into the machine the machine
shows us some additional information up
here deployment ID IP address when it
was booted free space and I can see that
this machine was created just for me it
has three and a half gigs of memory
which I can use to install whatever I
want and then now I see the Microsoft
security risk detection wizard the
Microsoft security risk detection wizard
walks me through everything I need to do
in order to submit software for testing
with Microsoft security risk detection
now the first thing I need to do I need
to upload my software to the machine if
I read through it says ok Program Files
is not a valid install location for the
entry point executable the entry point
executable is the specific executable I
am going to test today that entry point
executable is the calendar reader which
I just showed you which is the actual
EXCI file that I want to find issues in
so it says we recommend you install it
into the C app directory ok well what do
I need to do in order to do that I need
to open up Explorer I open up Explorer
by clicking on the windows explorer link
here I go to computer I go to local disk
there's a directory called C app there's
nothing in it I haven't yet installed my
application but remember I have queued
up my application I've already built it
we'll talk later and a separate video
about how to use Azure devops in order
to seamlessly automate this process by
creating a build task that just uploads
everything and submits it for you
but in the meantime what I have done is
I have created a folder here and this is
a folder on my local machine my local
machine folder is my executable my PDB
so I can get more information about the
results a DLL which this particular
executable is wrapping and I have
another PDB file for a full thing so
what I can do in remote desktop protocol
I can copy and paste I am going to copy
from my local machine and I'm going to
paste into the remote machine and
through the magic of remote desktop
protocol and the magic of Windows I am
able to actually move those files from
my local machine to the machine in the
cloud so what I've done is I've taken
the software I want to test I've taken
from my local machine where I compiled
it and made it ready I've put it into
the app directory the C app directory on
the cloud and
now I'm gonna go next I'm going to go
click next on the wizard
so it says great I'm ready to go I click
Next
what do I need to do well I now need to
tell the wizard what application do I
need to run during fuzzing so what will
happen is Microsoft security risk
detection is going to take this
particular application with this
particular command-line arguments and
run millions and millions and millions
of times across the lab of machines
created just for you in the Azure cloud
so I have to find out application ok so
I want to browse it's in the C app
directory remember we just uploaded at C
app and there it is Calendar reader so
calendar reader is my sample application
I've uploaded it to the remote machine
and then I just find it I click on it
and I say open and there it goes and
command-line arguments so I'm running
calendar reader XE and what happens is
this token test file will be replaced
with a uniquely generated file every
single time runs today calendar reader
doesn't have any additional arguments
but if I had additional arguments this
is where I would put them so I'm done
here I'll say next now we need to
provide what we call seed files so seed
files remember our initial files that we
use for testing the application they're
called seed files because they will be
corrupted through the process of fuzzing
and run millions and millions of times
with different variations and or defined
problems with the software I just
uploaded so I now need to upload seed
files into this remote desktop ok we
have created C seeds to contain your
files so I need to do I just did but for
the seed files instead of the
application so there's the application
you just saw me upload into the
application directory now I go to the
seed file directory I'm double clicking
on seeds there's nothing there but
fortunately I have locally a whole bunch
of calendar files basic bit mask
previously you saw me open up one of
these notepad to show you what it looks
like all of them are very similar and
just as before I'm going to select all
of them I'm going to copy them and then
using the magic of Windows and the magic
of RDP paste them and they move all the
way from my local machine up to the
cloud so basic calabasa all of these are
moving up to the cloud great and they're
all on the sea seeds directory so I
don't eat it
so I just say next the wizard then we'll
ask you a little bit of information
about your application this information
is used to help Microsoft security risk
detection get the best possible fuzzing
for you by optimizing the way it creates
the lab in the cloud so first can the
x-cube will be renamed and run in
parallel if I run calendar reader 1 and
calendar reader - will they get in each
other's way
so calendar reader this particular
application yes but you may have an
application that it has some global
State across the machine if that happens
then you want to say no only 1x
instances of the executable can be run
at a time for instance at Microsoft
Microsoft Word does not like being
renamed and paralyzed so that's a case
where we would run one executable a time
does the X cool run from scratch each
time without persistent state yes
calendar reader is independent calendar
reader doesn't drop files in the disk
calendar reader doesn't change registry
keys calendar reader doesn't change
global state but some applications your
application may be among them might
write a file the disk or you might
change a registry key depending on what
happens during an execution so I want to
say yes each runs independent but if no
you just let that you just click that so
then we know and does your ex people run
entirely in one process or process tree
so here calendar eater is one process I
would say yes
even if calendar reader fork the child
process but there are cases where the
client server remember
this is an entire VM you have the
freedom to install whatever you want if
you want to install sequel server on
this machine and then have your
application talk the sequel server on
the machine over and over again you can
do that if you do that you'll want to
say no there's out of process code next
it asks does your application
self-terminate so Microsoft Word again
who doesn't self-terminate you open up
word it'll render the image and it'll
just wait and wait and wait and wait
calendar reader on the other hand reads
the calendar file and then closes itself
so I'll say yes and my maximum runtime
that's really depending on my
application Microsoft security risk
detection asks this because we want to
be able to tell you not just when
there's a security issue but even when
there's a performance issue maybe
there's an input that causes your
application to hang or to run for a very
long time maybe you're running a service
that is very performance critical and if
something caused that service to run for
a very long time that would negatively
affect your customers so here I'm going
to say if there's anything that causes
the calendar for you to run for more
than five seconds even if it it doesn't
crash give me a heads up the wizard will
then run the execution the application
and test it before letting me send
everything off into the cloud so I'm
going to push this button say I want to
validate the job validating the job
means I'm gonna run the application with
the command line I gave it on one of the
seed files and say does it crash or
doesn't up crash so let's see it's
validating it's validating let's see
what happens let's see if it gets
through it so under the hood it's
running Calendar reader on one of those
executables and I can see the standard
output the standard error to help me
understand what's working so standard
output I'll take a look at that and says
great I see this and create calendar
from file name input that failed but the
calendar reader itself didn't crash so
I'm going to go ahead and say great
let's push it let's make it to go
forward and the final thing is
submitting a job the job is
figured it's ready for submission once I
push the button this session is
disconnected and I will not be able to
reconnect to the machine however
Microsoft Spheeris detection Connect
creates a mirror of this machine based
on the exact virtual machine
configuration I've created here so all I
need to do create a lab in the cloud
start millions of test cases running
just for me is push a submit button I'm
going to push the submit button five
four three two one
boom now under the hood Microsoft
security risk detection is taking the
virtual machine you can see it's already
disappeared and it's running it through
a process to generalize the machine and
create an entire lab just for you and so
if I see here up on the on the dashboard
I've clicked on the dashboard link again
and I can see that the the job the list
of jobs has gone from fuzzing or gone
from stays to submit to a validating
process this validating means that the
those configuration I've submitted is
going through a process being prepared
for creating a lab the lab is Grameen
created and then I will get a fuzzing
status just like this where millions of
test cases are being created just for me
and then just to close if you ever need
to reproduce than issue on the exact
same configuration as what Microsoft
security risk detection used to find it
you go to the open page here so the open
link it comes up and then you look at
the progress link and we see two things
one is the total number of inputs have
been tested so the metrics here so this
one has done one and a half million
tests since it was created earlier today
and then we actually have the remote
machine connection so we can connect to
a virtual machine in the cloud with the
exact same configuration as what you
submitted and that way you and your
colleagues can continue
work you can can to change things
without worrying about losing ability to
reproduce critical issues that's been a
tour of Microsoft security risk
detection
just to recap today we showed the
fuzzing portal we showed the results
what you get from fuzzing and how you
can use them to identify really critical
issues we showed you how to create a new
job and submit your own code so now you
can see it's validating and we showed
you how to understand after the job is
found issues how to reproduce them we
hope that you get a glove great value of
Microsoft security risk detection and if
you have any questions or any help
needed
we are fuzzing at Microsoft comm fuzzing
at Microsoft comm thank you
you